focus more you have to have absolute
focus getting laser focused on something
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out of the world now I started the one
rule series because I watch a lot of top
tens we make a lot of video content and
some of the rules come up over and over
and over and over again and so the goal
with this series is to bring together
some of the rules that keep coming up
consistently and share it with you so
today we're gonna learn how to get super
focused joy when one looks at the cream
standing on one leg completely focused
into the waters the crane with one
pointed attention is looking at the
waters as the fishes are swimming inside
the water the crane will allow the tiny
the small fish to swim around and not be
satisfied with them it'll allow the
fishes the small fishes to go around and
swim around the crane will focus and
wait for the big fish to come if the
qurían settles with the small fish it
lose the big fish and as a crane wants
the big fish it has to allow the small
fish to pass by and go around
similarly in life when you want to focus
on what is important we should allow the
small things to pass why we shouldn't be
distracted by the little things
sometimes they'll be interpersonal
issues and conflicts sometimes there'll
be some health crises sometimes there
might be a financial crisis so many
things keep happening in life let the
small things
vas-y and focus on what's important I
always am hard on like like deliver
platitudes on never be a quitter
platitudes like oh yes we can and yes we
will
is something gonna recently try to quit
like it gave up on threw in the towel
and didn't finish let me explain so so I
made this video lets you guys I think it
was okay like it wasn't bad bad but as I
was watching it back this morning about
to upload it I realized it like it
wasn't good either
it felt rushed and like so I'm bringing
up this failure this quit this quitting
I'm bringing this up to you now because
I don't giving up on that video made me
realize that I need to focus more on my
YouTube videos you know my head's been
really focused on on beam and on family
and all these other things happening in
my life but I still got all these crazy
ideas and instead of investing a bunch
of time to realize those ideas like I
used to I try to rush them and it always
leaves me with something that that's
unsatisfactory so I'm just bringing all
this up to you now to let you know I'm
gonna be giving my videos more focus and
more attention because this is kind of
the only thing that gives me a
tremendous sense of fulfillment in my
career
kind of in my life beyond family and
stuff and I missed that I want to get
back to that my life changed a couple
years ago when I discovered something
called the progress principle it is a
principle that was written about in the
Harvard Business Review it's based on a
tremendous amount of research done by a
professor over there and what she
determined is that people that feel
happy and successful and fulfilled by
their lives and work they all have one
thing in common they feel as though
they're making progress on something
that matters so I read this little bit
of research and I started applying it to
my life and what I do as stupid as it
sounds it really works I don't focus on
balancing everything I focus on just
making sure that I make progress on one
thing a day that's right you heard me
one thing a day that matters to me now
if I can make progress on one thing a
day that matters to me then I can let go
and let the rest of my day get hijacked
by kids by spouse by phone calls by
emails by social media by all kinds of
things that come up and tend to hijack
your day when you're a busy person when
you have a family when you're married
when you got a lot going on and so by
focusing on one thing a day I feel the
sense of control in the sense of
progress that science tells us will make
you happy and make you feel more
confident and actually make you more
effective at getting things done it also
frees me up to be more present with my
kids
Koby inc in this venture capital firm
her a lot to take on
are there are there other things it
seems like kind of each of your vehicles
maybe has a specific purpose are there
other areas and things that you're
looking at and want to pursue its pacing
right because you know we have there are
certain things that we want to get to
but we have to pace those out because we
have to have absolute focus on a few of
those things right Brian stipple fun and
the stories that we are creating right
and those are two lenses right now there
are other things that are going to come
but that's way down the road you know we
have to have a very very sharp lens
because we can do so many things may
that's the hardest part when we first
started it is you have so many people
coming from different different angles
different points of view and you can do
this you can do that and you know it's a
lot of them are you know very lucrative
offers but their small window my
opportunities
and the hardest parts been pushing those
to the side and going through things
that have a much much longer tail which
is risky but you know what are you gonna
do nice I think that's the best way to
go about it
your chances of success go up in direct
proportion to your ability to one pick
the right things to work on and then to
focus on executing those things it's so
easy as an entrepreneur to get
distracted we love shiny objects right
we love dreaming up new ideas and
chasing these different projects but if
you look at a typical entrepreneur
you'll see that so many of their
projects start and stop and start and
stop and you take something 10% through
or 50% through or sometimes even like
80% through but unless you're willing to
take it to a hundred you're not gonna
get the results you're not gonna get the
fruit of your labor because you're just
planting a whole bunch of seeds
constantly but you're never taking care
of that seed you're never watering it
right if you want to grow a plant
you gotta plant the seed you got to care
for the soil you got to add nutrients
you go out of water at daily it's got to
have enough sunshine you got to look
after that seed where most entrepreneurs
they don't they're starting stock by
starting to stop answering stopping and
you never actually get to where you want
to go people talk about diversification
you meet the diversifying you diversify
and well that's really great as an
investment strategy if you don't know
what you're invested into it's good to
have a big portfolio of different things
so that if one thing doesn't do well
something else is doing well but it
really sucks this business advice
because if you're trying to do 10
different things at once they're all
gonna be mediocre they're all gonna be
below average because you're going up
against people who are doing that
full-time and have their focus on it and
so it's much better as an entrepreneur
to one pick the things that you want to
focus on right and then to actually
focus on it do that work Andrew Carnegie
was once the richest person in the world
and he had a great quote saying how he
likes to put all of his eggs in one
basket and then you watch that basket
carefully right it's only a major risk
if you're not watching a basket if you
if you take your eye off the ball you
start looking elsewhere and then
something happens to your industry right
and so being the expert being the best
at what you do will always yield more
results more value
more money to you than being okay at 20
different things be the best at one
thing focus this question is from Phroso
mara new on YouTube when your home life
is less than desirable it's not where
you want to be living but you're trying
to break out how do you not let the
chaos around you affect your vision and
drive so this is a framing question so
what you want to do and this this Tony
Robbins asked this question I think it's
absolutely brilliant how is the worst
thing that ever happened to me
the best thing that ever happened to me
so in your circumstance how is being in
a chaotic home life the best thing ever
now I'll give you one example off the
top of my head and this is exactly why I
play first-person shooters can you learn
to stay calm in the chaos because my
friend have the chills if you can do
that it will serve you so well in every
single area of your life in a
relationship in business if you want to
be an athlete if you want to play games
like what ever it is that you do one of
the things that you're gonna have to
become great at is letting all of the
noise drift away into nothing and
getting into laser focus on that thing
that you're working on now when I give
advice like that to people they think
well how do I practice the amazing news
is the best thing that has ever happened
to you is that you have a built-in way
to do that your home life is mass chaos
so now you get a chance to practice I
have the chills you get a chance to
practice every day tuning out the chaos
and getting laser focused on something
that's framing now there are other ways
but that one is so powerful that I will
end it there focus on that it is
practice practice every day thank god
you're living in this chaotic
environment man congratulations
see most people think success is a
straight line I'm gonna get out of high
school I'm gonna get a job and
everything it's gonna be fun that's not
how it plays out folks okay this how it
plays out guy decides he wants something
and the line gets all squiggly see right
now guy decides over the summer hey man
I'm gonna go I'm gonna get this job this
summer and I'm gonna make some money
this summer and then he gets distracted
by the first squiggly
I don't know what he's doing he's
squiggling off because he's not focused
on his success he squiggles you ever
used this term squiggle yeah man I'm
doing a squiggle you know I'm gonna go
out and hang out with the guys this
weekend it's a squiggle it's off path
off purpose off potential and so he ends
up in a bunch of loops over here most
people get stuck in loops I did it when
I got out of high school I was in a lot
of trouble didn't have any focus wasn't
fulfilling my potential was distracted
didn't have a coach didn't have an older
brother didn't have a father lost what
am i doing
okay don't know where I'm going I know I
got this potential it's sitting there
inside of me it's a little candle
burning I know it's there I hadn't quite
put it out when I was 20 years old but
it was it was low any have you ever been
there what am i doing every day man why
am I getting up every day why am I going
to school I didn't even know what I was
going to school I was just going to
school I was just doing school I didn't
even want to go to school see I'm
squiggling around okay if you persist
and stay focus and surround yourself
with other people that persist to stay
focused who knows maybe you'll come out
the other end when I get to the court so
you know I have my bag and I'm wearing
my my hat in my in my hoodie this is my
office
like that's my workplace and I am like
I'm laser-focus and I've had that I mean
I I think it's that mentality that
whatever I just have that tunnel vision
and that's how I go and when I leave the
courts I got friends family jokes fun
like when I get to my office I close the
door and that's me that's you I really
feel very fortunate to do the job that I
do I mean my obsession has always been
film and so when I when I get a job
particularly a job as demanding and as
great an opportunity as this one was
that always becomes my obsession and
while I was shooting this it really was
there's never one second from the
beginning to the end of production that
wasn't dedicated
directly to this I mean I switched my
phone off switch the computer off and
didn't have any technology no
distractions for four months I didn't
make a single phone call I didn't send
an email to anybody like including my
girlfriend I just was very very singular
in my focus that she loved that's not a
very very understanding it supportive
girlfriend I must say this just of a
couple of weeks ago I was in
conversation with someone who is
considered some kind of an expert on
Internet affairs and social media and
all this so he's been looking at our
material in the YouTube and various
other platforms and I said ve I can give
you 50 times more than what is there
you know just people work on all the
thousands of hours of audio and video
that's there in the archive 50 times
more in a year's time we can multiply it
by 50 that much material is there he
said so guru already what is there here
you're throwing it all over the place is
worth a billion dollars
I said see what will I do with the
billion dollars my interest is seven
billion people I have no interest in
billion dollars what do I do with it
my interest is people
now I've got a really special bonus rule
with Will Smith that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know what are you going to
commit to commitment of the day you just
watch this video
don't just watch another video make a
commitment to change something in your
business your life your schedule what
did you learn from this video and what
are you going to commit to changing
right now leaving the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
I've always been really product oriented
you know it's like I want to win when I
do something I want to win I wanted to
be number one and I want to smash it and
I had a period I have a daughter and I
was over 15 year old daughter and she
really she got me and shifted my focus
from product to people it took a couple
of years but as soon as I gotten knocked
off of product and started shifting to
people the whole world opened up for me
again and acting opened up in a whole
new way to not go into day one of a
movie trying to figure out what
everybody has to do so we win versus
opening up and every person's a new it's
a whole new world meaning the character
you play all the people you work with
both absolutely you know generally when
I went into a product when I went into a
meeting with a director my focus was can
this guy when can this girl win and that
it was a it was a you know who's a
pathology that got broken for me a
couple of years ago and then releasing
that and just wanting to connect with
people and wanting to grow and wanted to
get new ideas and have new experiences
that don't have to have an outcome it
just opened up a whole new world for me
and I fell in love and then I couldn't
imagine what else I could do an acting
that could add so much to my life other
than acting raise your standard Apple at
the core is core value is that passion
[Music]
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details